at the end of the day it's about being a
football player I mean whatever your
sexual preferences is it doesn't matter
to us in our locker one we're going to
accept you with open arms and as long as
you're a good football player you can
help this team when that's what we
that's what we care about the st. Louis
Rams have been handling things right and
just like Michael Sam said I'm a lot of
guys are gonna there's going to be
critics and then there's going to be
lovers there's going to be haters but
the only thing that that's important is
if he can't play football and he said it
himself and I'm sure he's going to give
everything he's got I think Rams did a
great job picking up Michael Sam he's a
tremendous athlete in college and you
know
credit to helming I wish you the best of
luck with the rent organization if he
comes to work if he shows that he's
about his business I have no problem do
you think NFL culture the locker room is
ready for an openly gay athlete they're
not they're going to have to get ready
for it yeah I know about it and it was
the same thing no he's a ballplayer
really care about his on-field
activities and I all historians person
like you know boys for is that I didn't
have any say-so in the matter you know
people were to live their life and do
what they do everybody's more focused on
winning America's really focused on one
so on sexual preferences everybody's
just trying to get a super boring you
know the guy can play he completely if
he's a good teammate is good to me you
know it was a kid the guys are here to
God that's the only thing that matters
will you go out then you play the game
when you produce you quite a lot of
dollars a lot of haters and more
important you know you let it flew your
fire you know I've used that my whole
career you know people always say you
know he's never going to be this is too
slowly to this to that and you rise
above it all